okay clubhouse is having some
monetization problems around their
sponsorship of live rooms and i think
this is an important uh moment to pause
and talk about
why companies that have really high
valuations you know have to be careful
because they put themselves under a lot
of scrutiny so ashley carman is a senior
reporter who covers podcasting and audio
at the verge
and she just published an article
clubhouse needs creators but creators
need cash
and she tweeted about the faltering
creator program at clubhouse this
morning new clubhouse promised to match
people in its creator program with
brands to make their shows profitable
but according to six people i spoke with
none received sponsors of the three
slash 25 shows that might have only one
might have come through clubhouse itself
so clubhouse did an experiment called
clubhouse creator first uh program it
was an accelerator for creators and they
promised to provide equipment great what
equipment you need for clubhouse like a
headset like i'm wearing here 30 bucks
uh guest matching
help i mean that's really not a big deal
and quote concept and creative
development with the clubhouse team
ideas uh okay this seems like a terrible
idea a terrible deal as well as
promotional support including quote
design services for creative assets
whatever like
canva 15 minutes to make a an invite uh
jpeg
promotion with and off of clubhouse okay
that could be meaningful support in
building your audience that could be
meaningful and most importantly for
long-term creators clubhouse said they
would support by quote providing a
monthly stipend and matching you with
brands so you can turn your idea into
profitable creative endeavor according
to ashley at the verge these creators
were expecting to chat with brands but
quote when the time came it turned out
they weren't getting one-on-one meetings
with the brands instead
they would be pitching their shows to a
public room on clubhouse alongside
dustin or other creators where anyone on
the app could join the verge reported
that clubhouse did give out a stipend of
15 000 per show
and creators received support
making assets but that didn't work out i
guess that's 15 000 per show not episode
that's my guess fifteen thousand per
episode would be crazy so if i don't
know how many shows that stipend would
be but it's just you know that's not an
insignificant amount of money as an
advancing sponsorship and as ashley said
on twitter none of these shows have
ongoing sponsors the people i spoke with
say they won't continue making their
shows because they required hours of
work for which they won't get paid
they're looking to youtube and
podcasting instead long story short
clubhouse has a monetization problem and
with us
to discuss her story the author of this
great story ashley carmen welcome to
welcome live to the program live guest
here on restream hello
how are you so i just queued up the
story and um great job with the
reporting number one it seems like you
got access to a lot of creators
um and my take on it was
introducing money early to some nascent
platform like live rooms
probably a mistake for clubhouse and i
also kind of have the perception that
when a startup becomes worth 4 billion
they've got hundreds of millions of
dollars
it changes the relationship with the
creators and so if this was but a 50
million or 100 million dollar company
and they said hey we can't give you any
money but we'll promote you and we'll
support you and we'll give you shout
outs maybe this dynamic would have been
a little different and the people who
are creators might not look at this and
be like screw clubhouse uh only getting
15 grand
yeah i mean i think
beyond introducing money early it's
introducing these creator programs
really early we've seen the creator
programs pop up with like spotify does
it for podcasters but more broadly we
see facebook doing it with a billion
dollars committed through 2022 to bring
creators on we've seen youtube doing it
for it's tick tock competitor snapchat
was giving away a million dollars a day
for a while to get people on its
platform to do it's tick-tock competitor
so i just feel like you know giving
people a stipend is a great great thing
and you should pay people for the
quality content that they're making for
you but i think the issue is setting
expectations and being like hey we will
match you with brands so you can quote
unquote turn this into a profitable
creative endeavor and that just didn't
happen and that's where you have to have
the monetization features really built
out yeah and it you reported that they
gave fifteen thousand dollars to each
create each show which wasn't to be
clear for each episode
which would be the production budget of
like
you know uh you know a really big
podcast maybe um fifteen thousand
dollars for their
for how many episodes did they expect to
get for that a weekly for a year for six
months let's type in it was a
three-month program 12 episodes for
every show but yeah that i didn't really
get into as much in my reporting but
that also did although they were very
happy to be paid of course
it did become an issue because some
shows had many hosts and they had to
split that five thousand dollars a month
between hosts and also many guests
wanted to be compensated for coming on
the shows and that was money that would
have to come out of their pot so it just
it gets a little dicey when you start
dipping up what sounds like a lot of
money um among many people
yeah i for me i think almost better to
not introduce money at this stage but
when they also were promising sponsors
which made no sense because this is a
completely unproven medium
what is the expectation of what a
sponsor would get in your reporting you
said people would have 300 400 people in
the room even with promotion you also
pointed out that promotion fell off a
cliff
and so you had
an unproven technology
unrealistic expectations i think with
the creators um
and
uh traffic was falling off a cliff like
what is this what is sponsor going to
pay in your estimation for 500 live
users for two hours what is that worth
to a sponsor
i wish i knew how much that's worth i
will say
some some creators on couples who are
not associated with this program
have seemingly been able to do decently
well on there lea lamar is the icon
right now she's a comedian
i've heard her name come up as someone
who's making a living off of their
clubhouse existence
and others but the key thing with this
story was just that these were the
creators that clubhouse hand selected
and they weren't able to really secure
brand sponsorships unless they had their
own connections outside of clubhouse
which
wasn't really the goal of the program
and three of the 25 had sponsors at some
point do you know who the sponsors were
and yeah so did they renew because
that's the key like
if the sponsors you've got a business
right no my impression was that this
these shows are over is my impression
um the sponsors varied it was like a
camera show had sony as a sponsor he
would do giveaways i was unfortunately
unable to reach him but i'm unclear if
that sponsorship came through clubhouse
or his own connections there was a show
talking called sex profiteers who i
talked to that woman who hosted that
show my piece she had quite a few
sponsors but all of them came through
her own network because she's a media
consultant so she just like knows people
and can reach out but i don't think
anyone at least that i spoke to is
continuing to do their show so that
because of the fact that they don't have
sponsors to keep it going and
have to think about where they can make
money because we need to do that
it does seem to me that clubhouse is
not as effective as youtube
uh or podcasting and you kind of allude
to this that the creators were like
why am i here i could do a podcast i
could do
a youtube those ecosystems work better
for making money today
obviously right
well yeah i mean right now if you have a
podcast as you do you know you have a
monetizable archive of shows we're doing
this live but presumably you are
recording it and you will
monetize the back catalog if you want
and you have this archive that people
can revisit on demand that doesn't exist
right now in clubhouse of course they
can obviously launch a native recording
function and that solves that but
youtube that also has the same thing
except with video where you could do
that for your show as well where you can
just make money off of the views that
you're receiving without you doing
anything it just lives on your channel
if you listen to twist often you've
heard me talk about odoo's suite of
business apps a lot well on october 6th
and 7th they are hosting odoo experience
an annual event focused on building and
scaling your business it's free and
virtual and you can register at
odoo.comtwistodo.com
twist speaking of scaling your business
how much time and money do you waste
integrating a bunch of different
software products together let me guess
way too much well odoo is here to help
odoo is a suite of business apps that
runs your entire company on one platform
to streamline workflows by bringing all
your information together plus odoo's
integrations eliminate repetitive tests
and data entry if you only need two or
three apps to optimize your workflow
that's all you're going to pay for odoo
won't stick you with the bill or apps
you don't use odoo has an app for every
business need they offer 30 main apps
that are updated regularly and over 16
000 apps from their active open source
community you can keep your books tight
with their financial software and their
sales and crm apps will help you provide
a clear and organized view of your
business so your first app is free
forever and right now odoo is offering a
thousand dollar credit on your first
implementation pack that's no joke
thousand dollars off go to odoo.com
twist to check it out that's odo.com